hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on foreigner again we
got the third video of today we're gonna
be showing off a little bit of the new
effects especially the arcade effect
that is coming within season 12 we got
of course got Zhaan who soon Dow
whatever you want to call the character
I think it'd be a disservice if I didn't
use this character in arcade got the die
yeast set which I believe I mean
honestly like this is one of the most
fire sets that this character has and
you've seen the video that I've already
posted with the armor sets the dyi set
is definitely one of the most fire
armors with the with the dow prize being
like the best looking weapon like this
[ __ ] looks crazy
it doesn't match at all but I don't
really give a [ __ ] I'm just here to look
really pretty while doing it
so yeah we're gonna hop into some arcade
do the weekly quiz see if we can unlock
the new arcade effect and yeah let's get
started my HUDs gone
there we go I hug disappear baden-baden
crash forgot e-easy got my face
I'm so mad
[Music]
I love that I love personas so no way oh
I thought I thought I died
[Music]
oh [ __ ] let's go that's a way to long
that that was [ __ ] that took way too
damn long [ __ ] war would have bumpin
into me he kept trying to headbutt me he
wouldn't even throw heavies and all he
would do is just hit me in the head
constantly with his own head is [ __ ]
[ __ ]
I had the attacks dude last light
attacks I have Walt [ __ ] our perfect
character
oh dude she's so clean
Oh Harry it's too easy with this
character it honestly is just too easy I
love the way that this character can
just flow into so many different things
at once and it's like a never-ending
chain obviously good stamina so heavies
are gonna be an utmost importance
shaman as a shield go figure Raider
regens help go figure
and Valkyrie has increased oh so no
problem yeah what up
hi I'm just gonna go [ __ ] myself Ben all
right
[Music]
oh let's go buddy
get some shoes it's over it's over sit
down son
the effect I believe is called something
of rays or some [ __ ] it looks really
good seer of rays this is the idol
effect not really understanding the
point not gonna question it I think it
looks pretty cool we go over the
execution gonna get a little bit more
detailed there they don't mean to stick
into the box I really am trying to piece
together what the hell this means for
this effect but once again I'm not
really gonna complain too much it's a
cool effect on the less I definitely
think it's cool for the idol emote I
think depending on the emo it might be
really useful I think that one was
pretty a good representation execution I
feel like lacks a little bit but there
is I think my favorite part out of the
whole thing is that there's actually an
ornament and it's the seer of destinies
and I mean it just makes sense that this
would go with the other things that we
just solved this year of raise this
thing actually looks [ __ ] bonkers for
a character if you could get the correct
gear for a character it would look
amazing I don't think this is gonna look
great on every character like I think if
we look at warden maybe la bringer yeah
it's okay if we look at la bringer or so
she actually I'm not gonna do that
because I don't have la burner on this
account if we look at like somebody like
warden it's gonna look kind of awkward
as like a weird thing on his head so I
think if you're using one of the main
cast it probably won't work I think it
looks perfect for any of the new guys so
black prior your man Gunther hito kiri
they'll fit perfectly strictly because
of the shoulder pauldron that they have
like that's even though it's not that
great on BP it still looks real solid so
I think if you if you use any of the
year three characters I would definitely
pick up this ornament because I think it
looks pretty sick for at least half of
them so far yeah nothing crazy just a
short little video to show you guys the
new stuff coming with season 12 I got a
video coming out tomorrow it's gonna be
more based around Zhan who kind of what
the characters about like what the lore
is like what is this character right in
a sense cuz we talked about heat so kiri
being technically an assassin Jorma
gundar's an occultist for the giant
world serpent you know all that stuff
and bp's kind of like this night which
we all talked about for in previous
iterations of lore videos so we're
definitely to be covering soon died here
got to figure out what the [ __ ] is going
on with this character and what the what
though what's the history here be as
always like to be if you do enjoy guys
subscribe every new I cover the
informational side a foreigner that
being the balance changes they hear
updates the patch notes and leaks if
every kept up today with everything
happening for the world alone err I
never miss out on an update obviously
subscribe the channel
guys take care of girls today and peace
out
[Music]
you